Russia says President Vladimir Putin is
expected to attend the massive military
exercises underway right now in Eastern
Europe Russia and Belarus are staging
the simulated conflict involving troops
tanks and aircrafts NATO says the war
games near the Baltic Sea involve about
a hundred thousand military personnel it
includes firing nuclear capable
ballistic missiles Moscow claims the war
games pose no threat Elizabeth Palmer
will travel over the weekend with the
Russian military for an up-close look at
the drills she joins us now from London
Elizabeth good morning good morning
Russia stages these huge military
exercises every four years but this one
is different and it's more provocative
because the troops will be deployed
outside Russia and neighbouring Belarus
to the west and that means they'll be
along almost a thousand miles of border
with several NATO countries where there
is already a beefed up military presence
including 4,000 US personnel Russia's
exercises will involve as you mentioned
it's Army its Navy and it's Air Force
and electronic warfare troops the
Kremlin insists the exercises are
defensive not cover for an invasion like
we saw in Crimea for example and US
commanders believe that's true relations
between Russia and the West may be
hostile at the moment but there's no
sign Russia wants to pick a fight
however it does want to very publicly
flex its muscles as a warning that if
push came to shove it would be a
formidable opponent Jeff this Palmer
thank you